one day all of this will be yours other
people who are spending their whole time
on Eagle trips with configured society
in such a way that so many things can be
bought well if you're giving back you
took too much and human beings or do
scary things on their own there's
nothing in nature that grows
indefinitely except cancer how many
people do you know that in their death
that said boy I wish I had spent more
time at the office they say this seems
to be out of control pull the reins and
letting it sit there and not doing it as
an important part what am I doing this
for him he's the CEO and majority owner
of Semco partners under his leadership
the business grew from four million
dollars to two hundred and twelve
million dollars his innovative
management policies have attracted
widespread interest from around the
world
he's Ricardo Semler and here are his top
ten rules for success I thought MBAs at
MIT for a time and I ended up one day at
the Mount Auburn cemetery was beautiful
Cemetery in Cambridge and I was walking
around it was my birthday and I was
thinking and the first time around I saw
these tombstones and these wonderful
people who do done great things and I
thought what do I want to be remembered
for and I did another stroll around and
the second time another question came to
me which did did me better which was why
do I want to be remembered at all
and that I think took me different
places when I was 50 my wife another
nice hat for a whole afternoon we had a
big pit with fire and I threw everything
I had ever done into that fire this is a
book in 38 languages hundreds and
hundreds of articles and DVDs everything
there was and that did two things one it
freed our five kids from following in
the steps of shadow of they don't know
what I do which is good and I'm not
going to take them someone says one day
all of this will be yours
so the five kids know nothing which is
good the and the second thing is I freed
myself from this anchor of past
achievement or whatever it is and I'm
free to start something new every time
and to decide things from scratch I
think that a certain amount of ego and
vanity and self-esteem is absolutely
necessary I don't think it's possible
for you to to keep a a structured
personality with you giving up ego and
vanity of things it's yourself that is
that small percentage of religious
people are people or Hermits or people
who are able to go to that that extent
as on the other hand the other people
who are spending their whole time on ego
trips and making sure that they show up
and their photograph is in the paper and
they go to be seen and be seen and I'm
not in any of these in any of these
situations so I'm constantly managing
the issue of ego and asking myself why
am I doing this am i doing this is it
enough of a message is it important do I
do a few very very select of these or do
I do it all the time just to make sure
that I'm I'm busy I'm in the news or
whatever and so I don't do the second
part because the amount of things I
refuse per day is enormous and so I am
trying always to manage that issue but I
think without this force of of ego which
is within myself so when I'm giving when
I feel that I'm giving something
anonymously a school for example that
they will never know that it was me who
gave it it is
feeding my ego to feel good about having
done that but it doesn't have my name on
it I don't show up there so it doesn't
have that second part of the Eagle which
I don't think I need and I needed more
in the past and I started to tame it as
the years go by and so it's a very
delicate exercise but I think the people
without that first need to express
themselves or to have the ego issue
balanced end up doing very little as
well hmm
for the very little publicly because
that's what we're talking about for me
the the idea of success power money
together has never been a motto it was
just a realization that this was so
important to people in general but
success the idea that success is
connected to money to me is already a
strange combination it's there's a very
small correlation between success and
money in any case there's a strong
correlation between money and power
because we've configured society in such
a way that so many things can be bought
but success fits into another the other
Trinity of balance of security certainly
because it's much more secure in our
society to have a bank account than to
have none but it's not by any means that
this will enable you in any of the other
and any of the other factors but I think
the people that imagine that success
money power etcetera are useful only
believe in this for a while it's very
difficult to imagine that somebody
believes in this over the long run
because there's so many opportunities
and examples to see that there are so
many important things that you can't buy
with any of this I accumulated a lot of
money when I think about it you when you
think and you say now is the time to
give back well if you're giving back you
took too much
I see I keep thinking of Warren Buffett
waking up one day and finding out that
his thirty billion dollars more than he
thought he had and he looks and says
what am I gonna do with this he said let
me give it to somebody who really needs
this I'll give it to Bill Gates and my
guy who is my financial adviser in New
York she says look you're not you're a
silly guy because you would have 4.1
times more money today if you had made
one with money instead of sharing as you
go but I like sharing as you go better
our past is very determinant when you
think about Europe or the Western
Hemisphere in general we are stuck by
issues of the past
it is the past that holds back you know
and if you said that you were as I've
done in the past you said let me burn
everything let me get rid of everything
in the past you you're free to start
thinking about the future but if you're
still collecting the past and looking to
the past as a solution having history is
a very strong anchor you're unable to
move forward because there are
historical reasons why our tribe of
humanity is such a slow changer because
change is very very scary and human
beings or do scary things on their own
they take something much bigger to force
them into change what kind of identity
for every human being individual it's
the heart attack the car accident the
something that happened which was much
bigger than you which suddenly you wake
up and say oh my god I've been spending
all my life inside a box just working
for someone else oh isn't there a better
way for Humanity in general it is this
that suddenly it stops raining suddenly
everything goes crazy and you can't
control the climate so that's big enough
if the world were hit by a meteorite it
would be enough it takes enormous things
like that so we are a bit didn't
dinosaurs in that sense that we will
roam around and do our thing until we're
hit by something much bigger than us and
that's true even for the individual who
needs a heart attack to wake up to find
out the living working
much in each block of time your company
has grown your profits have grown your
own personal wealth has grown a company
that might have had a few hundred now
has five thousand what is it in all of
that still motivates you is it about the
growth is it about being bigger and
feeling good about yourself because
you've run something like that no as a
matter of fact now we've had a few
opportunities to sell to partners our
part completely and I'm very happy to do
that in a thousand people two thousand
people go at a stretch no I think I've
gotten over that there's something in
the beginning of a career where you
where you find that important but then
you realize that there's nothing in
nature that grows indefinitely except
cancer you know everything else and you
have the tall poppy syndrome rationale
here in an Australian the tree that
grows most is the one that's first
struck by lightning this is the idea
that you grow more you have more money
and you become better it's very very
silly idea and so what takes me let's
say from business to education or to
dealing with two-year-olds is that I'm
interested in human nature and why we do
some of the silly things we do is
there's not a better way to do this I
always come back to variations of the
the question that my my son asked me
when he was three we're sitting in a
jacuzzi and he said dad why do we exist
there is no other question nobody has
any other question you have variations
of this one question from three onwards
and so when you spend time in a company
in a bureaucracy in an organization and
you're you're saying boy how many people
do you know that in their death that
said boy I wish I had spent more time at
the office so there's a whole thing of
having the courage now not in a week
nine two months no not when you find out
you have something to say no what am I
doing this for stop everything let me do
something else and it'll be okay
it'll be much better than what you're
doing if you're stuck in a process so
when you think about the fact that we
allocate the same amount of hours what
is it that that we need to do or we can
do it's very easy today to set up
organizations that's the way we're set
up where we don't want to know how many
people work we don't want to
know exactly how many hours each person
works we're going to negotiate with the
group or with a person for a certain
result if the person is able to do it in
three hours or four hours or seven hours
we don't want to know we don't want that
control anymore we want to be able to
say look if you can distribute your life
differently in terms of where you are or
the amount of hours you work or between
idleness and leisure and the rest of the
things you want to do the framework
that's available today already permits
that it's just companies that are not
letting go because they think they need
control they want to know if the person
showed up etc because otherwise it's
unfair for the other one who worked more
hours and that's an obsolete rationale
it's an obsolete system and so it's
perfectly possible that's how we work is
to say give me this by such and such a
date and then if it's more hours less
hours or way to do it is none of our
concern and that solves the issue of
allocating too many hours when today we
don't need that many in order to produce
the same thing in a time in which things
seem to be lost in terms of control and
direction the first reaction is the same
one is you have with a horse when you're
when you're riding a horse and the horse
is going downhill and it starts speeding
up and losing control
you pull the reins which is the very
worst thing you could ever do because
then the horse has to pull up their head
and try to go down with you pulling the
rein there because you're afraid this is
the same thing that happens in these
organizations been happening in the
companies they say this seems to be out
of control
pull the range together and let's get
control of this thing that we're losing
and the fact is the more you do that the
more you have an entity an organism an
organization that doesn't know what to
do and is frightened and so this fear
this malice that's there in society
today and needs a completely different
organization is a completely different
architecture than this one of more and
more and more control and more slaves
building up something for you it's
something that says give up the reins
and realize that once the the horse has
control and the head is free that you're
able then to use
the best qualities of knowing where to
step in the things that came naturally
that came tribally already within is
many of which are much wiser than the
smart decision of control control is
smart but it's not wise yeah
control always seems smart it seems
intelligent to say ah so you tell me
where you were you tell me this you tell
me how much you spent you come here you
all come from everywhere around from 50
kilometers away and you take subways and
you take buses and you spend three hours
a day in traffic but once you come here
I can control you I know whether you're
here I know whether you came on time I
have a boarding-school mentality really
of control so if I send my kids over
there and I know that they're going to
wake up in urban over mathematics and
then biology said they're going to be
great it seems smart but it's very
unwise you have kids who then leave that
and who's thought they've wasted half
their life there and then they want to
do away with all of this organization
that was in place before well you know I
had a I had this unsuccessful career
Azzam
as a rock guitarist which was wonderful
I mean it was a wonderful period of my
life but it was very interesting because
it showed where where the limitations
are and why sometimes you want to do
something because you want to but the
combination of talent and time is not
right and letting it sit there and not
doing it as an important part we've all
learned how to go on Sunday night to go
to the email and work from home but very
few of us have learned how to go to the
movies on Monday afternoon and if we
were looking for wisdom we need to learn
to do that as well and so it's basically
what we've done all of these years is
very simple is use the little tool which
is ask three wives in a row because the
first why you always have a good answer
for the second why starts getting
difficult by the third why you don't
really know why you're doing what you're
doing and so what I want to leave you
with is the seed and the thought that
maybe if you do this you will come to
the question what for what am I doing
this for and hopefully as a result of
that and all
or time I hope that with this and that's
what I'm wishing you you'll have a much
wiser future thank you very much thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Marco aurélio asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Ricardo
Semler top ten rules meant the most to
you had the biggest impact leave it in
the comments and I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon